welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
controlling terpenes and cannabinoids
and flour and extract presented by dr.
Marcus Hagen founder and CEO of complex
biotech discovery ventures my name is
Xavier Gutierrez and I will be your
moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation and if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits app located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. dragon I will
now turn the presentation over to him
Thank You Surya welcome to my
presentations today as already mentioned
I will talk about our research and
controlling terpenes and cannabinoids
and flow-on extract because I think this
is a often overlooked aspects of
cannabis production everyone talks about
the strains and that certain strains
help others don't and it seems to be a
fixed idea that if you have a Sour
Diesel that's it and then nothing else
will change and it will always be the
same but that is not the case and so I
want to present our research of where
those changes happens and how one could
influence those but first let's just
talk about the basics of what we are
actually going to talk about in this
presentation
we talk about drawing and curing we talk
about extraction and post-processing
because in all those steps changes to
the molecular makeup can happen and to
make it easier for everyone to follow
what those changes are I devised
hopefully easy-to-understand
data visualization that shows both the
concentration and the ratio of different
cannabinoids and jerkings here in this
light we see that the central circle
shows in diameter the cannabinoid
concentration and then in the angles or
the the PI's the pieces of the pie the
amount or the relative amount of THC THC
acid CBD and CBD acids and those are
given the different colors the same
holes for terpenes which are shown by
the outer ring again the diameter of the
ring will indicate how much total
terpenes are in the flower or extract
and the different colored part of the
ring indicate if they are limonene
Boettiger file in pine pine in and so on
it is not so important to remember which
color correlates to which cannabinoid or
terpene it is more important to just
understand the basics of how this was
set up and then you can we compare one
set of rings to another set to easily
understand what might be going on in the
process so as an example here I showed
some strengths that we were growing in
the Southern California dispensary or
collectives that I was working in prior
we have here gorillas grew Kokiri strain
Sour Diesel lemonade haze and you
already can tell that those different
strains or better mentioned our cords a
cultivars show by their different ring
size for the terpenes that some might
have motor
or more flavorful than others the
cannabinoid ratios are all THC right so
our THC acid in the case has the flower
but we only grew THC strains no CBD
strains in the mix but they had slight
variations in how much potency they had
again I had to play with this
visualization that obviously there are
not more terpenes in the flour than they
are cannabinoids but as the terpene disc
is a bit more complicated I needed more
space to show it better and by just
looking at the color makeup of the outer
ring you can see that they're different
chirping profiles and that might
indicate different flavors Sour Diesel
and lemonade haze on the right are
mostly dominated by this gray aspect
which actually is mersin while the
cookie and Sour Diesel is mainly our
blue and even myself already forgot
which took in that stands for so but
it's not just that simple to look at
colors we should remind ourselves that
the cannabis flower not offers only THC
CBD and terpene but there are so many
more cannabinoids that are of interest
or should be of interest and they have
been already hundred and forty-four or
more identified and then there are over
two hundred terpenes that are already
identified in the cannabis plants we
currently track about 50 depending on
the testing laboratory and for
cannabinoids we generally only track 10
and state regulations of require less
now but we're still not done yet
the cannabis flower also offers
flavonoids that are considerably under
research right now because no one tests
for them you can't see them you can't
really work on furthering that aspect of
understanding but there's still other
molecules that might have a biological
effect on
patient or the consumer so I hope that
with the advancing science and the more
money that is poured into the industry
at some point we actually are able to
research those but let's now come to the
focus of this talk when we talk about
how we can track and hopefully effect
other changes that are happening in the
cannabis plant so at first there's the
drawing process everyone understands
that the cannabis flower of the harvest
has to be dried to preserve but it was
difficult for me and it at first to
understand what is done in drawing or
why it is done this way so we we
undertook some studies to figure out how
the drying process works or how we could
control it so he and this example you
already see that we if we do a slower
dry we have more terpenes left over and
here this is what we actually do in
drying we try to bring the water content
in the flower to a low enough level so
that no water is available water
activity for mold and bacteria to grow
on it and this number is normally
considered to be 0.65 for water activity
and as you see the day's progress along
the x-axis at the harvest the plant is
wet so water activity is nearly 1 but
over time this draw goes down and done
dips below 0.65 so now we know how we
can measure it and what target we have
so we can now play with different
conditions to change the the gradient of
dry elf basically water activity over
days and we found that when we played
with the drying conditions to come to a
slower dry to basically dry our plant
over a two-week period instead of a
one-week period we were able to produce
a dried cannabis flower with a higher
term
level compared to the faster grow
s this is a slower grow we had to be
mindful of not allowing for mold growth
but we kept that under control as well
so in the table on the right you see
that the terpene levels are higher into
two strains that we tested in these two
different drying conditions and after
drawing comes to cure the cue was always
a very weird thing for me I fall a weird
to put a cannabis flower in a bucket or
a glass jar and then just wait I'm still
trying to learn more of what actually is
happening but my first study was to see
how can I did the dry curing is also
just storage so how can I store cannabis
over a long time and preserve it so that
we don't have the couch lock we don't
have the CBN after a year of storage so
I was researching with a partner partner
company to see if different atmospheres
packaging atmospheres would influence
the terpene and cannabinoid
concentrations in the flower and we did
we tried vacuum packaging nitrogen
packaging co2 packaging and argon those
atmospheres or modified atmospheres
might be in all of you might remember
those when you pack it when you have
other food goods that you buy in a store
because they often packaged under
nitrogen and sometimes co2 particular
field by sparking water so we do have
graphs associated with it and we do see
it in the cannabinoid in general
decrease in potency we also did check
for decarboxylation and CBN growth and
there were CBN development there was not
much CBN developed in the time frame
that I did do the study and for the
terpenes
total doping levels we did we do see a
little dip but then they grow back up
and while initially this looks weird I
have seen this and multiple experiments
on multiple repeats it appears that the
cannabis flower is still somewhat alive
that some kind of terpenes are still
produced and if we would have a half an
hour talk about just terpenes and
storage we could go into finer detail
that the ratio of different cannabinoids
of different terpene story changes and
let me just jump back a slide because if
you look at the terpene rings of the
different atmosphere packaging its
vacuum nitrogen co2 in our air or
actually not a eyes are gone when you
look at the colors you see that the
relationship or the order of colors does
change the blue and the yellow is always
the most dominant second most dominant
but their colors just after that so at
the and nine o'clock seven o'clock up to
eleven o'clock
part of the ring the order of the
coloring and therefore the terpenes
changes so we do not only see a change
in overall terpene production or terpene
presence but also in the relative ratios
of those turbines so we seem to have a
handle on changing the the flavor of the
cannabis cultivar okay so moving on from
there we've now talked about how to dry
off and how to cure or store our
cannabis and well that we kind of
influence the cannabinoids and chirpings
in that step but let's now talk about
extraction and even before we get into
extraction we have to consider how do we
feed our cannabis flower into extraction
vessel
we properly wanna powder because the
powder might offer us a better packing
density better flow behavior of the
solvent and so on and so forth but I
wanted to know does that actually change
the outcome and surprisingly it does
depending on how we mill or not mill our
cannabis flour for the extraction
process we actually changed the outcome
or the the oil we collect from it but
first we had to check do we destroy the
cannabinoids do we destroy the THC that
was a question that I heard from a
former colleague of mine quite a few
years ago and I thought it was a weird
question because a mill that can destroy
THC would be awesome when I get an all
the price for it but this after thinking
about a little the question does hold
true dust here does the the grinding
with it may be heating aspect or the
higher surface area doesn't lead to a
change in my molecular makeup so here on
the Left we are looking at a graph that
shows the decarboxylation ratio of THC
to th the acid in the flour before
milling non ground which is the column
all the way to the left and then ground
and different conditions food blender at
a point five millimeter sieve all the
way to a 10 millimeter particle size and
how this mill looked that we used to get
the precise particle sizes between 0.5
and 10 millimeters is shown in the
picture up on the right
it's a fridge mill where we can change
the particle size depending on just
putting different sieves and and the
residence time in the mill is short
enough to not heat the flour so there is
a apparent slight difference in the
decarboxylation but it all falls with a
measuring errors and can be considered
as not important and then also on the
terpenes
we did not see a change in
terpene levels in the flower after
milling but we do have to say that is
just after directly after milling if we
would try to store milled cannabis over
a longer period of time let's say a week
we would lose most of the terpenes the
part of the surface area is large enough
that just everything about rates so mill
and extract directly do not try to store
milled cannabis that's a really bad idea
so now the effect of mill particles on
the extraction itself so on the Left
again we see the cannabinoids the yellow
bars and we are looking at recovery of
THC so I I calculate how much THC is in
my starting material on how much THC is
by weight by mass in my product and we
we are hanging around 30% recovery which
would be a pretty bad extraction if you
want to do that commercially but for
various reasons of camera I camera
chemistry I had to go with initial rates
these are initial rates experiments
everyone we had a chemistry class might
remember those I could not take it to
completion because then I wouldn't see a
difference if everything completes I
don't see a difference so I stayed at an
initial rate surprisingly non ground
cannabis flower actually gave us quite a
decent level of recovery one food
blender ground cannabis was not very
well received in recovery and the two
millimeter or the smallest particle size
tested in the experiments was the best
here and also for the terpene recovery
we saw the highest numbers the highest
number of recovery in the two millimeter
particle size and the the reason why an
on-ground cannabis has a high THC
recovery is a little longer story but
it's it hopefully becomes apparent in
the next few slides ok so what I also
should not forget is packing density
does affect
it's how the extraction goes I tried my
hand on a visualization to show this
what we are seeing here is a a diagram
of a column of an extractor column if
you think of a long pipe that is how it
would look from the top the flow of our
supercritical co2 is from top to bottom
and the the green color which would be a
whole square is the percentage of THC in
the flower in the position along that
column so we had nine percent THC in the
flower throughout the column and then if
you extracted in a loose packed state
which would be the blue Shaw triangle
nearly you would see that at the top of
the column every everything of the THC
has been extracted but in the middle of
the column you still have about three
percent left and at the bottom of the
column the flower still has three and a
half percent THC in it but it's a
relatively good extraction and we
removed it most of it throughout the
column but if a full pack or a half pack
column where we just put in a bit of
cannabis tempered it down packed it
really tight put a bit more in you do
see a change in the cannabis extract or
the THC extracted and the bottom part of
the column where more THC stayed behind
and therefore it was a less effective
extraction um we started these
experiments because we were looking at
channeling and we did not see channeling
but we saw this change in where the THC
happened
happens to reside and it appears that
the THC is extracted preferentially at
the beginning of the flow so at the top
and the co2 that comes to the lower part
of the column at that point already is
saturated in THC and can't take up
anymore so one would have to wait until
the top is extracted before the bottom
can continue
actually be extracted and a few more
aspects to it and please consider this
is an experiment that worked that is
particular for my this one instrument I
worked on a slightly different machine
might behave somewhat different but it's
still interesting to keep in mind that
one should test it because one or two of
those tests can save you a lot of money
over the long run yeah
so how did we actually do the
experiments so here we we did the
experiment on an apex supercritical co2
extractor and the conditions are given
in the left on the left side we used
three kilograms of plant matter so for
the American audience that's about six
and a little pounds of cannabis flour
per run and then we did two fractions
first a Terp infraction and then a
cannabinoid fraction and the times were
chosen to do initial rates so none of
this was extracted to completion and on
our first fraction we had a terpene
fraction we want a high level of
terpenes a high concentration and that
is shown on the left side of the graph
at the left graph that shows that the
concentration of fraction one and
terpenes is very high for the food
blender the two millimeters and the ten
millimeters so that's a very good
choking fraction as the picture shows on
the right the graph on the right shows
the chirping concentration in f2 so
where we wanted to cannabinoids to be so
there we want a low number for the
concentration of terpenes so two
millimeters seem to appears to win and
then looking at the cannabinoids again
in fraction one we want no cannabinoids
and most mils cannabis was very
effective in that and the non ground
cannabis was very bad quite a high any
amount of THC was already extracted and
then we want a high concentration of
cannabinoids and the second fraction and
here two millimeters and six millimeters
appears to be the winner so overall we
can save that and the
two millimeter or the smallest particle
size tested gives us the best yields the
best recoveries but also the best
precision in our cannabis production and
the high concentration of cannabinoids
infraction one for the non ground is the
reason why overall the non gon had a
quite high recovery because it it
started extracting cannabinoids before
it was done with the turkeys which it
shouldn't have been been doing okay so
when we now look at the extraction
condition itself so past the milling now
actually how we do we change the co2
conditions to extract different aspects
of the flower we can actually separate
terpenes from cannabinoids as I already
showed in the last few graphs for the
milling study but not only that if we
would have a strain that is 50/50 or one
to one in cannabinoid in THC to CBD we
might actually be able to split those
two into two different fractions where
we can enrich one and THC in the other
one and CBD and this is all based on
some data from work I had produced in
optimizing the co2 extractor the first
graph you see here is this response
surface of the space of different
temperatures and pressures of how it
affects the THC recovery in the
supercritical space so I locked or
mapped all possibilities of changing
temperatures and pressures and how that
affects my extraction yield and I also
did this in the subcritical space where
the graph looks slightly different but
all of them point in highest pressure
and highest temperature being the best
for extraction and when you think about
house you to works in the liquid or a
supercritical state high pressure and
high temperature combined means the
higher density so having a thicker
solvent so to say
gives us better extraction abilities
because THC is pretty bad in dissolving
co2 so as denser solvent dissolves more
THC so in our trap infraction that was
the green experiments earlier on in the
milling we looked at the terpene
fraction or percentage of terpenes not
of the total recovery because we can go
to about 100 percent recovery in all of
those experiments anyway but we wanted a
precise clean to have been fraction and
as you can see in the picture on the
left so this is the response of
supercritical space and here we have it
for the subcritical space both of them
seem to point at the sucker at the super
critical point so at the lowest pressure
with the right temperature and one is
the low temperature in a supercritical
and in the subcritical it's the higher
temperature which then is pointing at
this super critical point yeah but now
that we have all these response services
we can actually learn some more in-depth
aspects of cannabis extraction in co2
and here I compare the supercritical to
subcritical because I've heard a lot
that subcritical is the best
supercritical is the best and that might
all be nice and true for whoever
believes in this I don't really hold
beliefs I try to compare to validate it
or base it on data so therefore I could
use my experiments to compare and when I
look at THC recovery at a set time I can
recover more THC in the supercritical
space as all the graphs already were
indicating the higher density gives us a
better solubility and therefore faster
recovery or faster extraction
supercritical co2 is more dense than
liquid co2 so there we go we get better
recoveries in the terpene fractions we
actually extract a little bit more
terpene 63% and super low space compared
to 52%
no sorry I misspoke the terpene fraction
meaning the percentage of the makeup of
the liquids that is terpene is 63% in
supercritical so more than half or two
thirds 2/3 of the liquid at terpenes
while only a half of it is terpenes in
the subcritical space so it's a it's a
nice a pure choking fraction in
supercritical space at higher yields at
a 5-2 percent while compared to 34%
yields in the subcritical space so I for
my processes and what I want the
supercritical seems to be far better
than the subcritical other things we
learn THC extracts faster than THC
assets so meaning the neutral
cannabinoids are more soluble and co2
than the acid cannabinoids here we see
that the starting material has about 8%
decarboxylation
in one experiment of 40% and the other
experiment after 7 hours we do have an
enriched decarboxylation ratio of 25% so
more THC then compared to THC acid then
in the starting material but when we run
this for experimental completion at 22
hours we are back to what we started so
we didn't decarboxylate in the reaction
but we did in extract THC first and THC
acid second that's why those numbers
change and therefore you can play with
your THC to GFC a ratio and you don't
have to go fully activated or feel fully
decarboxylated or non decarboxylate not
the car works at all you can actually
set it somewhere in the middle if you so
choose or unneeded and then also CVD is
more soluble in co2 than THC s and here
unfortunately we did not really have a
one-to-one strain so my numbers are
really really small but what you can see
here is that we we start with a very low
CBD ratio compared to THC which
increases after seven hours but then
goes back to the starting number at
comply
of the experiment indicating that CVD
again extracted first before THC came
off and again this means we can change
the THC to CBD ratio if that is of
interest so if anyone has a problem with
hemp having too much THC in it and you
need to preserve suppress the THC amount
you might not have to use a column
chromatography afterwards you might be
able to solve that aspect already in
your extraction aspect and if you have
any further questions at the end there's
my email and I'm happy to help you with
any questions that arise and a bonus
point CBD acid decarboxylase
slower than THC acid for you that might
be important that if you were used to
decarboxylate in your THC acid extract
on the hot plate after extraction and
you now got into the hemp business those
numbers are off and you have to change
them why that is the case I recently
figured out with some help from the
University of British Columbia and
Vancouver we did some computation
chemistry experiments and I will present
those results soon and we hope to have a
publication out in the next few month so
if you really enjoy geeky science we are
happy to help you with that as well and
then going through the data we can
actually enrich not only c VAR d but
other cannabinoids might also have a
different solubility behavior and
therefore we can change the CBG ratio in
our extract depending on our conditions
so what if we want to take it really far
now can we change terpene ratios and it
is possible so if you consider that
sativas are rich in monoterpenes and
indicas are rich and says Quatro greens
based on a study by Hauser come on the
Dutch cannabis market
I was looking can I change the mono -
Cisco terpenes with this year to extract
ideas we can
it's a small effect but nevertheless we
can use it we could use it to buffer any
variants that come out of aggro and I
remember the first time I did an
extraction my boss told me it doesn't
look right and there's an organic
chemist I was always wondering I never
think about how something looks like I
think the most I ever produced in my PhD
thesis was 10 milligrams of my material
so I've never ever looked at how how my
molecules appear or present themselves
if you read scientific papers there's
always an an oil and off-yellow oil or a
transparent oil so basically no one
really seen it and no one really cares
but the cannabis industry you do so yes
he is my visual guide to cannabinoids or
cannabis extracts this is what your
maybe I used to all your extract looks
when it comes out of the co2 extractor I
call this diarrhea but you can also when
you play with your extraction process
you can get these very nice solid THC a
rich extracts out they are really fun to
play with and you can do some cool
things like supercharge your pre-roll to
40% Plus THC or you can use it to treat
a young kid with epilepsy that shouldn't
get high I'm happy to to point you in
the right direction depending on your
needs and also if you want a big
cartridge maybe you want your looking
like this when it comes out of the
extractor so depending on how you set
your co2 extractor you can produce
different extracts and this visual eye
guide should already bring home the
point I want to make throughout the
whole presentation that the cannabinoid
and terpene ratio makeup is not static
it's not just depending on which strain
you use it's the it also highly depend
on what you do and your extraction well
all the rest of all the processing
aspects
so another processing aspect is
decarboxylation decarboxylation or
activation as that is like prefer to we
refer to in the cannabis industry
it appears that often cannabis extracts
are they are extracted and then they're
put on a hot plate and they're just
boiled and cooked or put in an album and
you just wait until they stop bubbling
and you're done with your
decarboxylation
but while you do this you actually
expose your extract to air and s your
metal handrail in your office might tell
you that oxygen and heat might not be a
great idea because it rusts the same
happens to cannabinoids they don't rust
but they do degrade and that's what I
wanted to show with the visualization
here when you do decarboxylation on the
air you not only have your THC but you
also have other things like CBN you
might get Delta eight THC and a host of
other molecules that I'm still busy
trying to identify right now so should
be able to control you have to
understand what is happening and the
current method is you put it on our
plate you at some point take a take a
sample you ship it off to a lab where
you put in your HPLC and if you shipped
it off a week later you have a result or
if you have your own HPLC twenty thirty
minutes later you have a result but that
is not in any time frame that is useful
if you do a decarboxylation that only
takes now on your plate so I developed
an IR monitoring system where we can
basically in real time track the
decarboxylation so here on the Left we
see overlaid IR spectra of our cannabis
extract while it goes through the
decarboxylation step and we one would
have to zoom in and it still wouldn't be
helpful because ir doesn't correspond to
molecules on Peaks but it stretches so
you have to use higher mass
to understand what actually is THC a
what is THC but with that we could train
the machine to show it this th see this
THC acid tell me when all the THC acid
is gone and then I stopped my
decarboxylation and having that
understanding allowed us from what
normally looks like this really dark tar
in the picture on the left or the middle
aspect of the screen we are getting the
these decarboxylated oils that are still
vibrant orange from the carotenes
because when carotenes degrade and under
oxygen they turn black and that's what
you see in the middle so now that we can
control the endpoint of decarboxylation
are more precise with the IR we can now
get better extracts and to just show to
you that this actually works is here you
see our on the Left graph you see the
THC growing in and the THC acid
depleting over time and we correlate the
IR measurements with LC measurements and
we have a very good agreement that there
is a good agreement we show on the right
and the two graphs that the predicted
decay box the predicted percentage of
THC by a via our via compared to the
reference THC from the HPLC is in near
perfect agreement so we are very
confident that this is a nice method for
the production industry track the
decarboxylation so and last aspect of
post-processing would be the
distillation I have heard I've seen that
not all the THC actually distills over
but it turns into something else what is
it I can't yet fully say I'm still
running experiments right now actually
this week we hope to get a better handle
on it we're basically doing desolations
and then we trying to sort through the
mess and pick out every molecule and
trying to figure out what it is and it
will still take some time but I
hope to figure out what those color
aspects and my visualization actually
represents and when I know what it is
maybe we can do something about it and
prevent it so we now talk about I
presented to you that different
processing aspects lead to different
challenges and different influences on
the makeup of the cannabis flower so I
thought I'd actually bring you an
example a real live example that we came
across we had a male patient in his mid
thirties with severe epileptic seizures
throughout the day and he sought
treatment so he bought a CBD tincture
CBD THC tincture 3 2 1 and I'm sorry
that the screen already shows the whole
slide so you can get the punchline at
the end I normally like to bring this up
slowly but basically he'd take a
three-to-one tincture it worked for him
I came back for the next fry an X bottle
and then it didn't work anymore and
while he was really scared and everyone
else was very concerned I was actually
happy from a scientific aspect not from
a personal it was a bad experience for
those patients and I feel with him but
it did show what I was expecting to see
or was fearful of and now I had a
real-life example that we had actually
changed from diamond OG to lemon hey
eliminate haze for the THC aspect of our
tincture the tincture was made with
isolated CBD and THC coming from an
plant extract we removed all terpenes
prior to formulation and we actually
tested the two bottles of time and OG
and lemonade Harry's and the CBD and the
THC aspects of the formulations were
identical so my colleague was very very
good at mixing it the THC acid and CBD
acid aspect of the formulation world's
nearly identical CBN there was much of a
difference CBG not much of difference
pH CV president both and then in CB GA
and CBC we do see a slide we finally see
some difference between the two but as I
told you earlier they're over a hundred
and forty cannabinoids already
identified so is it those two there are
no present an absence that do the job or
is that the ones we don't need to test
for I can't say but what I can say is we
switched him back to Diamond og and the
seizures disappeared again
so we had that soft at least for this
one patient but it also should led you
to consider that if cannabis helps you
for your problem that doesn't mean it
will help everyone or every cannabis
will help everyone or even that a
different strain will help you with your
problem and then at the aspect of
different production processes might
change it so if you buy a diamond OG
from us or from the next next over
manufacturer even if we started with the
same clones we might end up with
completely different molecular makeups
in our products so therefore this gets
very very complicated very quickly and
the aspect of which cannabinoids are
actually present I hope that in the next
few months I do have a test laboratory
up and running that can offer those
analytics but lets us get to the
conclusion and the shout outs to
everyone who helped me because that's a
lot of work and I couldn't do it all by
myself
so the colleagues that helped me on the
job were Taylor tri-blade cards and
Alison justice so if you see those odd
events or add company gatherings please
say hi on the company sides most of the
work was done at outcall that's a
dispensary and cannabis producer down in
San Diego that provided us with the
plant material and the space to do the
experiments then Nate's controls helped
us
with the drying experiments the
packaging experiments for different
atmospheres we're done with Hinkleman
was there vacuum packaging systems so
that I can infuse them back with other
gases the III experiments were done with
the help of perc and Alma they provided
us with the instrument and support the
milling experiments were done with and
for fridge and the extractor was
provided from a pax and we work closely
with them to get the machine working in
a way that we like that to be and then
finally as the introduction said I am
now living in Vancouver Canada as
cannabis is legal in Canada on a federal
level so I can actually pawn up with the
local university the bank UBC to do more
research and that is what my company
does we do custom research in support of
the industry so if you want to know what
are your cannabinoids beyond the ten we
can do those tests hopefully soon we
also have a smoke machine where you can
smoke a vape cartridge but it doesn't
listen on you that smokes it but the
HPLC so you can see what comes out of
your vape cartridges what all's work
best with the materials to choose or we
custom design those IR analytic systems
to be included in your processes if so
needed I think that's enough Tooting of
my own horn if you want the slides I
think they're provided by the by the
host lab roots but I also put all my
presentations up on SlideShare and the
link is given on the bottom left those
also include all the my past and future
presentations so you can flick through
some other experimental results and if
you have any questions the email is
given on the bottom right and with that
I thank you very much for your attention
and I hand it back to Serbia
Thank You dr. Hogan for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible and before we go I want
to let everyone know that this webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through June of 2019 and as a final
reminder our speaker will follow up with
any questions you've submitted via email
and that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye